[Music]
there aren't any mother day songs okay
[Music]
for Mother's Day Mother's Day we go to
brunch Mother's Day nope I'm not gonna
just go out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh no it's mom I love you mommy
hey it's me
red you know the guy everybody hated who
kind of saved the whole island anyway
war with Leonard in the pigs what are
you gonna do I'm a foodie still going on
those what and BOM and Chuck are doing
whatever they do I eat dirt
[Laughter]
and me well I still have some anger
issues but I'm finding healthier ways to
deal with it Fred I know we've had our
differences but we've discovered that
there's a third island one good reason
why I should believe you now show you
the proof will deepen
really this is a hundred times just
don't think you're gonna be compatible
with the team oh wow it is such a
pleasure to meet not you but you I like
her
we gotta get to the island is what my
assistant was going to say
[Music]
this is the amazing team I've been
working around the clock for well that's
disappointing
what will break in and deactivate the
weapon weight was amazing we gotta get
that key card hello fellow Eagle God how
he's doing a voice yeah I'm just gonna
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]